in death stranding there are plenty of
human enemies out in the world that can
instantly ruin your day so we've
compiled a guide to give you the edge
while taking them on mules are the first
type of human enemies you can encounter
this band of troublemakers attacked
Porter's on-site and live for the high
of stealing and hoarding cargo however
their main perogative isn't killing
think post-apocalyptic team rocket mule
camps are always surrounded by a
proximity fence that's triggered when
you pass their borders there are a few
quirks to this fence though the main
trigger is cargo so if you're not
carrying delivery cargo for an order you
will not appear in their skin which
makes it easier to enter without being
seen once you obtain the sensor
Nullification skill for your odor deck
from the time fall form you can time
your sensor scan to cancel their ping to
sneak in undetected past their fences
once you get past their borders you need
to start strategizing a way to whittle
down their numbers use the odor duck
scanner and the environment around you
to sneak into their camp take cover
behind rocks or in tall grass and scout
out their positions and then take them
down one by one by using the strange
from behind you can incapacitate them
you can also use the bola gun to tie
them down from a distance
they'll keep in mind it may alert others
nearby if you want to get loud there are
many ways to take down mules in early
hours you don't have much equipment to
deal with them besides your fists and
your strand so it's usually not
recommended to run into mules until you
get some better gear to use the strand
hold l2 to ready yourself and hit or two
to parry physical attacks the timing is
lenient so don't worry about precise
timing but make sure that you're facing
your attacker also it takes a second to
ready yourself for the parry so give
yourself enough time to get into
position while you can instant ko a mule
by binding them with a strand you are
left open to attack during this
animation so be careful it's also
possible to dodge attacks with nothing
equipped in your hands hold r2 or l2 and
then jump to dodge use this to counter
attack enemies and hit them from behind
in an absolute pinch you can also rely
on the hematocrit aids you picked up in
chapter 2 to stun enemies as well even
though it says are designed for BTS if
you're not too worried about collecting
the materials that the Mules drop you
can also use it against them
you can pick up dropped cargo by holding
l2 or r2 over it and do a powerful melee
attack with a square but you can also
throw it back by releasing l2 or r2 in
the middle of your melee swing try not
to do this with your own precious cargo
as a contents get heavily damaged both
punching and straining mules are great
ways to take them down but they're both
slow and if you're being attacked by
multiple enemies it's usually a recipe
for disaster
generally try not to get into this mosh
pit situation in the first place as the
worst thing to do is fight a whole gang
at once and a one-on-one fight these
enemies pose little threat but as more
and more their friends arrive that's
when the situation starts getting out of
control especially when they're shocked
Spears are raining down on you later in
Chapter 3 you'll get access to much more
fun equipment to take on mules such as
decoys bola guns and special grenades
vog and smoke decoys are useful to start
the fight off with as it's pinged as
fake cargo it's best to drop it right
where the ping location is and relocate
somewhere else
enemies will pick the decoy and set it
off as a trap bola guns are fairly
straightforward holding the trigger down
will widen the bola shot and make it
much easier to hit your targets this is
a great weapon to make sure you're not
taking too many on at once make sure you
kick a tied mule so they don't come back
to bite you later if you can afford to
try to go for the headshot
this will wrap around their neck and
knock them out instantly rather than a
body shot where they'll be temporarily
tied down instead smoke grenades are
great for crowd control as enemies
caught in a smoke will be temporarily
stunned and will cough uncontrollably
any smoked enemies are also findable the
best uses for defense use it when you're
surrounded and escape as it doesn't
affect yourself stun grenades as
advertised stun enemies but more
importantly vehicles use one to stun
multiple enemies off a truck and disable
the vehicle temporarily for most stun
grenades are also great and are sticky
so attach them to enemies and goodies
and have some fun careful not to be
caught in your own blast though
probably the most underrated weapon of
all is a sticky gun
this weapon rips cargo right off of
meals and brings it to you on a hook
shot hold down our chew or else you to
catch stolen cargo and throw it right
back they shot it at an enemy it will
turn them around for you perfect for you
to do a nice takedown it also has a ton
of ammo so it's a worthwhile gun to
fabricate starting in episode 4 you'll
start running into a new faction
terrorists these dangerous foes are far
more bloodthirsty and strategic than
mules and most importantly they carry
real guns in this case you'll now have
to start thinking about equipping armor
and blood packs and putting those cryo
bites you've been collecting the use but
for the most part the strategy it takes
to overcome them as similar to mules
previous tactics using knockout
equipment still come into play here but
by this point in the game you'll also
have access to guns as well make sure to
get non lethal rubber rounds or else
with real guns you'll have a lot of
cleaning up to do after make sure to
check out our other video explaining why
real guns can be a problem
make sure to sneak up in as many
terrorists as you can before turning on
the fire use a non lethal assault rifle
a long-range and the riot shotgun a
short-range if you can afford to without
exposing yourself too much use a ride
shotguns small stunt to close a gap and
then take them down to save some ammo
take cover keep scanning and take the
high ground to come out on top
ultimately once you take down a whole
mule or terrorist encampment you'll be
rewarded with free rein to all of their
useful cargo we know during your journey
you don't always have the luxury to keep
all this nifty equipment on you so pick
and choose your equipment and your
battles wisely hopefully this guy will
keep you on top of the battle and for
more deaths training guides and content
keep it here on gamespot
you